Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I’m
going to explain an American dystopian
action horror film called “The Purge.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, we see
several clips of people killing and
assaulting each other, and houses being
burned. Several shootouts and gang fights
resulting in hundreds of deaths are seen.
In 2014, the Republican and Democratic parties had
collapsed in the US. An economic crisis gave rise
to a third political party called the New Founding
Fathers Of America (NFFA). The party leader is
the U.S. president, Bracken. He and the others
from his party formulated an extreme law called
“The Purge”. Every once in a year, one night,
for twelve hours straight, all crimes are legal
and no emergency services will be available.
People are allowed to release their inhibitions
in any way they choose, including murder. It is
now the year 2022. Because of the purge, the
United States has become virtually crime-free,
and unemployment rates have dropped to 1%.
It is the day of the Purge. James Sandin drives
back to his home in a wealthy gated community to
be safe during the night. He sees his neighbours
place blue flowers in their front yard, to
show their support to the purging system.
James too has a blue flower, suggesting
that he is a supporter of the Purge.
James is planning to spend the night locked
in with his wife Mary and their children,
Zoey and Charlie. Zoey is in her
room with her boyfriend Henry.
James is not fond of their relationship,
so Henry sneaks out of the house.
As Henry sneaks out, the two see a
neighbor sharpening a weapon for tonight.
As Mary places the flowers in their yard, their
obnoxious neighbour, Grace Ferrin, approaches her
with some cookies. The two talk about the lockdown
happening in an hour, and go their separate ways.
James’s son, Charlie, is then seen playing
with his creepy robotic toy, Timmy.
Later that evening, the family happily has
dinner together and goes to their study room
to prepare for the purge. First, James turns on
the surveillance camera placed around the house.
Then, he turns on the security system
which brings down metal doors and windows,
closing every possible opening in the house.
Lastly, he brings out a gun from the safe for
protection. Then the family sits down to watch
the official initiation of the purge on TV.
It is announced that the Purge is fully in motion.
Weapons of class four or lower are now legal.
However, all other weapons are restricted.
Government officials of ranking ten or above
are immune to the Purge, so an attack on them is
still considered illegal. After a siren blares,
any and all crimes including murder will
be legal for twelve continuous hours.
Police, fire, and any other emergency
medical services will be unavailable. As the
broadcast completes, the siren starts to blare,
indicating that the purge has now started.
James tells his kids that since they can afford
protection, they will be fine. Zoey then goes
back to her room. Charlie, on the other hand,
doesn't seem to like the idea of the purge,
but James tries to make him understand,
saying that it allows people to take out their
frustration. He too then goes to his room.
Zoey hears a thud in her room and finds Henry,
who had snuck in before the security system
was engaged. Henry tells Zoey that he wants
to talk to her father about their relationship.
Since James cannot throw him out of the house
during this time, he thinks it's the perfect
time for him to convince her father.
Everyone in the house relaxes, while
Charlie plays with his robot Timmy.
He moves Timmy around the house, surveilling
everything through Timmy’s camera.
He sends Timmy to the study room and
watches the surveillance footage.
He sees a man running away from someone,
and stand right in front of their house.
Charlie runs to watch the surveillance
footage from near, and sees a man begging
for help outside their house. In order to
help him, Charlie disarms the metal door.
At the same time, Henry makes his way
towards James' room to talk to him.
Realising that Charlie has disarmed the metal
door, James runs to the study room and quickly
puts the metal doors down again. However, the man
gets in. James, Mary, Charlie, and the man are in
the room when suddenly, Henry fires at James
from the stairs. He wants to kill James so he
can be with Zoey. The two fire at each other and
Henry gets shot. Seeing this, Zoey saves Henry and
takes him away, after which James looks around
to see that the strange man is gone too.
To ensure his family's safety, James takes his
family into a safe room and goes to look for Zoey.
He finds Henry’s dead body in the room. We see
that the stranger is standing right behind him
as he checks Henry’s pulse, but James doesn’t see
him. Charlie sees a group of people approaching
their home through the camera and calls his
parents. The group is masked and has weapons
in their hands. The group leader stands right
in front of the camera and starts talking.
He knows James’s name and tells the
family that one of their targets was lost.
The group got to know from their neighbour
that the target had run into their house.
Now, the group wants the target out, so that they
can kill him. If the family doesn’t send him out
in time, they threaten to get inside the house
and kill everyone, as they know a way to break in.
Then, the group cuts off the power supply
to the house, and everything goes black.
James tells the family that they have to find
the man and force him outside, but Charlie is
reluctant to the idea. James and Mary go out to
search for him. Charlie too looks for him with
the help of Timmy, and finds him hiding behind the
sofa in the living room. He blinks Timmy’s light
at the man and makes him follow it; Charlie is
trying to help the man. He takes him to his room,
where he has formed hiding in the closet.
Timmy flashes his light at the hiding,
and the man sees it. He finally goes
inside it, after thanking Timmy.
Just then, the Purger's leader calls James to
the front door. The two talk through an opening,
and James explains to him that they are not trying
to save the stranger. The leader then shoots one
of his own men to threaten James, while claiming
that the group’s equipment to break the door is
arriving soon. James, fearing his family’s
safety, gets back to look for the stranger.
He goes into Charlie’s room and sees the
stranger holding Zoey at gunpoint.
As he threatens James, Mary comes behind
him. James and the man get into a fight
and James accidentally shoots him. He and
Mary then tie the man to a chair. However,
the man starts to fight back. James makes Mary
pick on the stranger’s wound so he would give up.
Charlie watches all of this in horror.
They prepare to give him to the gang,
but realize that they would not
be any better if they did.
The stranger too offers James that he will
go outside so that he can save his family.
James realizes how wrong they are, and tells
Mary that they will have to fight back and
defend themselves. Just then, the purger’s
equipment to open the doors and windows arrive.
They attach huge chains to the doors and pull on
them, finally breaking in. James hands Charlie a
gun and tells him to hide in the basement. He
forgets to untie the stranger in a hurry and
gets ready to fight. Zoey hides in her room,
while the stranger tries to free himself.
Now the purgers start to break in. One of
them opens the main door for the leader,
and he gets in with his gun. As they hide around
the house, one purger gets in through the basement
door and attacks Charlie. As he is about to
kill him, James shoots the man from behind.
The group maniacally roams around the house.
James fights and kills most of them, but the
leader appears before him and stabs him. As James
lays in the ground dying, the leader politely
thanks him and kisses his forehead. The others
start to destroy everything in the house.
Charlie is in the study room,
looking at the surveillance footage,
when he sees two people approach the
purgers in their front yard and kill them.
He notices that the people are their neighbours,
Grace and her husband. Slowly, all the neighbors
gather to help the Sandins. But at the same
time, Mary is caught by two of the purgers.
The girl purger tickles Mary as she begs for her
life. Just when she is about to hit Mary with her
machete, their neighbor, Mr. and Mrs. Halverson
shoot the two dead. Mary goes to help James.
But before they can do anything, the leader walks
into the room. He clocks his gun and thanks them
for their sacrifice. Zoey suddenly appears and
shoots the man dead before he can kill them.
The family sits around James, crying as he dies
when the neighbors arrive. Mary thanks them
for their help, however, it turns out that the
neighbors want to kill the Sandins themselves.
They are jealous of James’s money and want to
purge themselves of the jealousy by killing
the family. They then drag James’s body to
the other room and take the others hostage.
Mary begs them to leave her kids and they tie all
three of them with duct tape. The neighbours then
hold each other's hand and thank the new founding
fathers for providing them with this opportunity.
They have always been jealous of Sandin’s perfect
family, and when the purgers broke into the house
today, they saw the opportunity. As they are about
to harm the family, the stranger from earlier
saves them. He shoots Mr. Halverson dead and holds
Grace at gunpoint. The neighbors now stand in
a line in front of them. Grace asks Mary to kill
them and put an end to this; however, Mary has had
enough of these killings. She tells everyone to
stay there until seven when the purge stops.
A few minutes later, everyone is sitting
at the dining table together in silence.
The stranger still points his gun at
the neighbours to keep them in check.
Charlie and Zoey cry, while holding their father’s
hand. Suddenly, Grace tries to take the rifle from
Mary’s hand, but Mary breaks her nose instead,
yelling at her. Finally, the sirens ring,
indicating that the purge has completed.
Mary tells everyone to get out of her house;
the stranger too leaves at the end, after Mary
thanks him for his help. The movie ends as the
three surviving members of the family look at
several dead bodies lying outside the house.
A voice in the background narrates that
this was the most successful purge to date.
Other news reporters claim that the streets of Los
Angeles are filled with dead bodies and the stock
market has risen to its highest. In the end, a man
says that he is no longer proud to be American,
because both of his sons died in the purge.
That was my recap for the movie ‘The Purge’
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like
to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.